alors qu'hier comment pourriez vous
définir le jeu de jacqueline maillan à
s'adapter à un petit moment on commence
à avoir plus qu'assez on en parle c'est
une rupture c'était tout ce qu'elle
rajoute entre les textes et je pense à
une expérience puisqu'il a décidé de
jouer ensemble
c'était décrire une scène un peu plat
très anodines et que la faire jouer
d'une façon un peu nul au départ qui
vous pensé pour la jouer à des as au nul
par exemple et après comme my ans
faisait du maillot est paralysée du
poiré essayer de faire après la même
scène en faisant du robin palmade
carrière avec la même scène michel roux
jugera est donc dans le décor je vous
fais le début elle assise sur le canapé
et chantal oui et après je vous laisse
le faire donc je vais vous le faites
nuque l'on sent drôle d'ailleurs fort
bien comment derrière la france
aider tant de bruit de clôture entre et
puis démerdez vous vous m'entendez ou
pas c'est très agréable ou pas je prends
mes marques et la porte du fond s'ouvre
c'est lui qui entre à pas de loup ap la
série où ça
chantal tu rentre tard ah tu dors pas
c'est mais je rêve que je te parle
excuse moi mais je pensais qu'à cette
heure si tu dormir est déjà et moi je
pensais qu'à cette heure si tu serais
déjà rentrée est bien moins gentiment je
rentrais tard pour être sûr de ne pas te
réveiller trop aimable tu étais où je me
mettrai à bout et qui me dit tu n'étais
pas en train de faire la fête avec les
copains
même quand il ya un texte anodin
moi je te le dis je peux l'appeler si tu
veux être le confirmera qu'est ce qu'il
veut c'est bien plus tu me prends pour
une bille elle est sûrement dans la
combine pas trop tout couvrir
elle ferait n'importe quoi enfin
pourquoi je te mentirais si je te dis
que j'étais tranquillement en train de
me taper maîtresse je peux me croire bon
sens je me mettrais ma main à couper que
tu regardais le foot chez des copains
je fais rhin je te jure qu après avoir
mis un somnifère dans sa pure et j'ai
fait le mur par la fenêtre de la cuisine
je suis directement aller sauter
christiane 2 0 le psg ils sont pas
fortiche 3 0 bingo si on était sûr la
tuer fait comme un rat
oh [ __ ]
donc c'est faux c'est bien alors
d'accord si tu veux la vérité on
regarder le foot en faisant l'amour avec
tes copains non avec christiane ma
maîtresse et personne d'autre mais enfin
quand c'est que vous allez admettre un
jour qu'on peut passer une soirée avec
sa maîtresse en toute simplicité sans
que ça cache forcément un mensonge
honteux at avoue que c'est honteux
d'avoir passé une soirée avec des
copains
j'avoue rien du tout je n'ai pas passer
cette soirée est à penser à ta femme
toute seule chez elle
non je reconnais j'ai eu un moment
d'égarement je n'y ai pas pensé
écoute maman je me dis c'est vraiment
simple on continue à habiter ensemble
tous les deux titres est amère pour l
habiter chez sa femme
c'est ça que tu es en train de me dire
dans les grandes lignes oui et à penser
à ta maîtresse le mal que tu vas lui
faire pour écoute tu as gagné
alors cette fois j'y vais pour de bon ou
c'est moi j'ai mes copains regarder le
foot il s'en va oh la la
photo roger à des costumes de donald
cardwell
c'est comme ça on a on appris la
nouvelle j'ai froid léthale la
découverte du texte et fait donc là
c'est vrai fini oui y'a pas de preuves
je dois vous dire que je ne suis pas
dingue dingue on les écoute on a dit on
va déjà on va le faire
alors ça c'est ça c'est il faut pour
tous les trucs garder bien à des tailles
de l'agent l'importance hop ça marche
toujours à la fois féminin puisque ça
mais je veux aller trop loin non plus du
rang d'art haha tu dors pas si si si si
si l'âge d'or cela se voit complètement
mais ce rêve que je te parle je pensais
qu'à cette heure-ci dû dormir et déjà
alors moi qui marque c'est de couper le
vent de façon de penser les choses moi
je pensais qu'à cette heure ci lui ça
les a entraînés dans les biens moins
gentiment je rentre tard j'étais
pourquoi on dit alors je vous parle a
dit oui et ben et bat pour être sûr de
pâtes réveiller trop aimable et son
orchestre jouer les grands
alors tu étais où je te parle là je te
parle là moi je te parle c'est moi où tu
étais un peu moins drôle quand tu veux
moi je suis prête d'accord je suis ma
maîtresse
ah bon alors qu'il me dit que tu étais
pas en train de faire la fête avec des
copains qui m'ont alors qui crie je
dirais un effet je prends le temps je me
dis moi je te le dis oui on peut
l'appeler elle confirmera voilà alors là
tu me prends pour une bille un waf eux
d'où une plus récemment la bourgogne
pour couvrir le pré n'importe quoi enfin
mais enfin c'est pourquoi je te
mentirais si je te dis que j'étais
tranquillement en train de me taper ma
maîtresse qui peut me croire % clé
pendant des clés quand je dis que
l'excusé la maîtresse l'année mais un
peu éculé lâche peu d'accord je n'ai pas
compris le choix là non parce que moi je
me mettrais ma main à couper qu'il est
en train de regarder le foot avec des
copains est grave mais pas si tèlman
trop évasif et noir mélangé les jeunes
enfants alors je vais la mettre là je
m'en vais parce qu'elle a su surmonter
regarde pas plein
et moi je dis qu'après avoir mis un
somnifère dans sa purée ou cette purée
ou plus rien j'ai fait le mur par la
fenêtre de cuisine je suis directement
aller soit écrit cette fois c'est tous
les jeudis 2 0 le psg sont pas fortis
dans les aigus sont loin non 3 030 bingo
ah ah ah ah ah ah non on veut garder
mais tu es pris tu es pris par la crise
et comme un rat partenaires alors
d'accord alors si tu veux la vérité aux
regarder le foot en faisant l'amour ça
lui arrive avec tes copains non avec les
siennes ma maîtresse et personne d'autre
même le chien était deux salons salles
basses à l'eau sale autres suspects sont
pas souvent non je connais plein qui a
pointé à gros seins mais d'accord
d'accord
non bien facto s'exhaler admettre un
jour qu'on peut passer une soirée avec
sa maîtresse en toute simplicité un
souvenir comment alors tabou que c'est
honteux d'avoir passé une soirée les
combats
j'avouerai du tout cela les accessoires
c'est pas mal j'aime bien aussi un oui
ce qu'elle vaut rien du tour tutoie les
effets de levier de changement tout à la
vapeur tout à la vapeur sel poivre et à
basseau ça alors j'ai déjà vous rien du
tout je l'ait pas passer ses soirées
s'arrête dans les dents fait alors état
penser à ta flamme tout seul pauvre
penser à ça aa à aa
non non non non je veux faire une orgie
non non non non je reconnais j'ai eu un
moment d'égarement j'ai pas pour ces
écoutes
mamie ou alors ça c'est facile tient la
change j'écoute ma mine c'est vraiment
ça qu'on continue à habiter tous les
deux pays alors qu'ils quitteraient ta
mère ta ta ta ta ta ta ta manif est un
jeune mamie gérer
quand j'étais à 16h16 le maillet cette
mamie 32 ans lundi guinness en attendant
bas pour aller habiter chez sa femme
mais c'est ça mais c'est mais alors bon
alors mais c'est ça c'est ça qui est en
train de me dire et les grandes lignes
oui bon été j'entends pernicieuse où ses
doigts du baba peux pas me ridiculiser
toujours en écoute à gagner qu'elle
fascine j'y vais comme les tandems
l'écran quand un qu il défend quand
est-ce qui va le décider à grandir moi
je crois que c'était plus drôle la
première version 1
bravo bravo